get ready for battle my friend the Omni
crisis a global conflict between the
forces of humanity and autonomous
machines while some considerate in the
distant past the fires of a second war
are flaring up in Siberia aleksandra
sorry yah Nova was a star of the Russian
athletics program until she rushed to
enlist in the local defence forces after
hostility erupted in her homeland now
Daria serves her country proudly using
her immense strength to protect the
people in the nation that she loves
zaria is arranged warrior who uses
shields to absorb damage and convert it
into energy that increases the strength
of her attacks Zara's trait is energy
whenever her shield abilities absorb
damage she gains energy as her energy
level increases so does the damage her
abilities in a tax deal this increase is
not permanent in the energy bonus
decreases over time Saria's first basic
ability fires a particle grenade at a
target location after a short travel
time the blast deals damage to all
enemies in the impact zone particle
grenades damage increases based on
saria's current energy level activating
her next ability personal barrier grants
azaria a temporary shield that absorbs a
set amount of damage before expiring
similarly her shield a liability
envelops a teammate in a protective
shield the damage absorbed by both
personal barrier and by shield Ally
increases her energy total
zaria specializes in gravity
manipulation and her first heroic is
graviton surge shortly after being
launched this gravity bombs impact draws
enemy heroes towards its center her
second heroic expulsion zone is the
polar opposite upon impact this bomb
creates a pulsing area of denial that
pushes away enemies dealing damage and
slowing
zaria is an expert in negating enemy
attacks while using the resulting
increase in ur damage to punish her
enemies all of her damage scales as her
energy level increases including her
basic attack and her damage dealing
abilities at maximum charge zaria gains
a staggering increased to her damage if
you want to reach her full potential
identifying the right moments to use her
shields is a must while personal barrier
is the primary tools are you uses to
tank damage and gain energy don't
underestimate shield ally use it to save
allies under heavy fire and snag a nice
damage bonus as a reward I'm your
shields carefully as Arya becomes
vulnerable when her defenses are uncool
down
Zara's particle cannon fires a beam of
energy that deals hey OE damage to all
enemies caught within it aim carefully
and it can chew through enemy minions
make sure to pay attention to your
positioning that the beam traxxas are
his target particle grenade is her main
damage ability and holds multiple
charges use it to poke groups of enemies
from range or take down a fleeing target
early on zaria is that her best wall
paired with an ally when shielding both
herself and a teammate zaria will make
the most of her abilities and their
potential to increase her damage
on the heroic side of things use
graviton surge to draw enemies to a
target point while your team unleashes
heavy damage alternatively expulsion
zone will not only keep your enemies
away but when fully charged can deal a
whole lot of damage
zaria will be deploying into the nexus
suit ready to protect her allies
overpower her enemies
want to keep up to date on the latest
reveals spotlights and overviews and
make sure to subscribe to here's of the
storm here on YouTube thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the Nexus
give me your best shot